sabe aquela pessoa pentelha chata porque
fica perguntando tudo quer saber o
motivo fica enchendo o saco de todo
mundo não gosta de seguir as coisas como
elas são assim está sempre perguntando
criança criança que fica mais porque
isso porque aquilo porque tudo eu sou
expulso um carro feito esse sim eu quero
mudar tudo o tempo todo fui perguntando
tudo que enchem o saco disso vou começar
essa conversa da gente com algumas
perguntas que ninguém precisa responder
mas pelo menos se perguntarem por dentro
que é o seguinte você
vocês acham que colaboram para fazer uma
cidade melhor cada um aqui
individualmente pensa nisso você tenta
fazer uma cidade ea sua cidade melhor
todo dia mas como é isso é contra a
favor de um governo que pensa o governo
e tenta fazer essa cidade melhor a
partir disso você já tentou fazer a
partir de um governo
como é que é você toparia entrar no
governo e dentro dele começar a tentar
mudar este governo mas é como é que
seria seria tipo escolhendo partido e
consegui a ideologia do partido eu vou
ter que seguir algumas regras
mas e se o partido fosse a sua cidade a
ideologia você tem que seguir a apple
voltou do dia acordar dormir pensando em
fazer uma cidade melhor
a minha cidade um pouco melhor vocês já
pensaram em ser prefeito da sua cidade e
tem essa responsabilidade de tocar uma
cidade no dia a dia
acho que se a gente pegar aqui um pouco
a história da humanidade a gente lembra
que a gente não lembra a gente sabe que
as pessoas estavam ali vivendo em vilas
em pequenos grupos e elas sozinhas
tomavam decisões não escolhiam para que
a gente vai fazer
e elas também dividiam as tarefas para
organizar essa vila alguém lin o outro
caça o outro faz alguma coisa ea gente
vive ali tranquilo
a população foi crescendo cidade foram
se formando
e a gente começou por um lado eleger
representantes alguém que vai tomar
decisões para agentes e pelo outro lado
a gente começou a contratar governo
pagar imposto
alguém limpasse a nossa vila linda que
organizasse que fizesse uma rua que
trocasse uma lâmpada enfim com as redes
sociais comunicação crescendo mais a
gente foi vendo que isso não era não
tava indo muito bem
assim a gente começa a ver que as
pessoas continuam a tomar decisões não
adianta eleger a gente continua querendo
tomar a decisão ea gente quer pelo menos
que esse prestador de serviço é que a
gente contrata seja bom aí manifestações
de junho no brasil elas são belas
ilustram isso as pessoas foram à rua às
ruas não foi por 20 centavos foi porque
estavam insatisfeitas queriam tocar
tomar mais decisões e queria um melhor
serviço e aí pensando nessa loucura
ainda tipo como é que a gente pensa em
solucionar essa história eu vou contar
um pouco da minha história em si eu
trabalhava com o marketing político
digital um bom tempo e aí nas eleições
de 2012 para a prefeitura então para a
cidade assim né
como é servir a uma idéia lá em recife
na época estava trabalhando trabalhei
várias campanha mas em recife foi uma
delas
e aí pensando como é que a gente fazer o
evento começou a monitorar rede social
ver o que as pessoas falavam no facebook
e no twitter
acho que todo mundo aqui faz isso aqui
são alguns exemplos de pessoas que
reclamam do buraco da rua e que propõe
melhorias e querem mudanças na cidade o
tempo inteiro
a gente começou a pensar em fazer uma
campanha colaborativa vou montar um
programa de governo colaborativa com
base no que as pessoas acham ea gente
começou a usá-lo a fan page do candidato
pra perguntar coisas sobre as cidades
ae o recife antigo seguro ba e seguro e
vivo você moraria nesse bairro que é
quando a gente vê 28 mil 500 pessoas
participam de uma enquete de um
candidato em uma semana ou isso é muita
gente mas vamos fazer outras 51 mil
pessoas respondendo enquete de um cara
em uma semana
só assim por cento da população da
cidade inteira é muita gente tipo era
uma coisa bizarra a gente fazia pensando
no bairro lino e bura que é uma
comunidade lá no recife
e mesmo assim 18 mil pessoas responderem
uma semana só que no facebook é um
negócio muito estruturado na época o
negócio perdido ali porque precisa fazer
isso de uma forma diferente
mas uma pergunta como é que a gente faz
isso de uma forma mais estruturada ea
europa eureka ali naquele momento de boa
ideia veio
vamos fazer uma rede social para a
cidadania como conectar as pessoas as
cidades um pouco mais a gente viu que
existe um vazio enorme entre o cidadão
eo governo poder público as decisões
coisas sempre vão construir uma ponte
essa ponte ganhou uma marca dessa ponte
começou a ter um nome ele colabore
virou nome que alguns falam colabora e
foi meio de propósito para que o ponto
fosse um o ideal de colaboração a gente
tem que fazer essa rede social para a
cidadania com colaboração nessa ponte
começou a ser pensada pelo lado cidadão
primeiro tinha que ser transparente
tinha que ser interativa amigável ali
como rede social que tem bastante
engajamento tem que ter tudo de uma
forma muito bem estruturada para que
seja levada para o governo e ele possa
tomar ação a gente pensa na ferramenta
que vai ter problemas vai reunir os
problemas da cidade que a gente vê isso
no dia a dia mas as pessoas também têm
propor soluções e elas devem avaliada
feedback constante do catálogo por trás
e aí vêm os nossos três pilares
principais fiscalize propõe a vale como
funciona o supersimples fiscaliza e você
vê um problema um semáforo quebrado uma
iluminação com defeito você vai tirar
seu celular você tira uma foto
pega sua localização você descreve
colocando uma categoria pública
o proponha bem parecido você vai lá uma
rampa de acessibilidade na faixa de
pedestre enfim dezenas de categorias lá
você escolhe sua localização pública
fica disponível lá avaliação mesma coisa
escolas hospitais aqui o exemplo de 10
pontos sendo avaliado
tudo isso fica disponível uma linha do
tempo da cidade que todo mundo consegue
ver e isso pra cada município do brasil
são 5.500 municípios que têm dentro da
plataforma
qualquer pessoa de qualquer cidade pode
baixar o aplicativo e pode começar a
usar ea história começa em 27 de março
de 2013 a gente resolveu lançar esse
negócio
primeiro pensamos só em recife era
fechado só para recife e é engraçado que
eu tinha trabalhado na campanha do
prefeito e eu fiz a um eu junto com meus
amigos sócios a gente fez essa
plataforma pensando pô vai fazer um bem
enorme para a cidade
vai ser muito legal a gente super
animado e eu encontrei com cara da
prefeitura um secretário da prefeitura
no dia que a gente lançar e eu disse o
agente foi essa ferramenta é super legal
ele não não tem interesse não está bom
mas é bom porque vai ser a cidade é
legal e tal não tem interesse no timão
veja médico é legal ele se você lançar a
gente vai brigar mas quando vamos fazer
o nosso hoje lançar hoje
e aí o cara que teoricamente pode ser
meu cliente estava fazendo pensando nele
o cara diz que a gente vai brigar se a
gente lançar esse negócio ea gente fez
até mais as pessoas começaram a publicar
ali ea gente pensou só que ele vai fazer
vou mandar manualmente tudo da
prefeitura se ele não quer receber o
problema dele vai receber pessoas estão
publicando vamos mandar tudo manualmente
para lá
aí a gente ganha um prêmio de melhor
aplicativo banda do mundo
isso é muito doido
isso é muito doido porque disputa eu sou
aquele cara eu não imaginava ganhar um
prêmio de bolinha de gude e sabe melhor
jogador italiano enquanto o mundo é você
ganha um prêmio que porque é pra fazer
cidade melhores é um cheque do faustão
daquele tamanho do nosso gigante assim é
muito louco isso ea gente começou a
pensar essa ponte pelo outro lado também
pensar pelo lado do governo é construir
um painel de gestão tinha que ser o
maior painel de gestão da cidade onde
eles conseguissem ver tudo de uma forma
gerencial ver foto abre ticket pensar
com detalhes de tudo o que consegue
saber para que a pessoa public chega na
prefeitura
lá o responsável volte para alguém de
comunicação isso seja passado para o
cidadão
eles podem ver tudo no mapa vem
relatório estatístico em tempo real de
tudo é uma ferramenta para solucionar os
problemas da cidade pra escolher
projetos são projetos legais mas ele
pode mudar alerta
isso aqui é um exemplo super legal aí
mandam água para as pessoas pararem de
jogar lixo na rua porque estava
entupindo as galerias e com a chuva
estava deixando tudo alagado
a gente começa a pensar nessa ferramenta
e organizar a vila de novo sabe com as
pessoas participando de tudo assim no
dia d
a gente pensa o outro lado vão começar a
consultar a população por seppala seu
aplicativo
recebem um a prefeitura vai te perguntar
se é uma ciclovia na sua cidade você vai
lá escolhe se quer se não quer que a
cidade vai ficando melhor com base na
colaboração das pessoas a gente começa a
dar uma ferramenta para as pessoas
voltarem a tomar a decisão da cidade
e aí em 27 de março de 2014 um ano
depois daquele fatídico dia de cara
queria brigar comigo curitiba lançou
colab a primeira cidade a adotar o
colapso como ferramenta a plataforma
digital oficial da prefeitura
depois de niterói veio um santo veio
porto alegre vieram 75 cidades aí nos
últimos 18 meses
e aí veio até 13 teresina tem um caso
legal da fonte aí que eu vou te contar
que é o caso de dona esmeralda uma
senhora que quando eu não conhecia
pessoalmente não conheço pessoalmente
ainda mas ela vai lá e por fazer uma
publicação reúne algumas coisas de
problemas da comunidade dela e ela
pública e ela quando tem um negócio
atendido pela prefeitura em 15 dias
antes pô
há dois anos eu tentava falar com alguém
e não consegui achar que resolver sempre
tem que ir no lugar em que no outro e
ela tem um negócio resolver em 15 de
junho
para dona esmeralda antes ela precisava
falar com o líder comunitário que é
levar para um secretário que ela vá pro
vereador em think finalmente chegar na
gestão para que o negócio fosse
resolvido ea gente corta tudo isso aí a
gente ganha um prémio de 125 melhores
aplicativos do governo participação do
mundo pela onu
lá em abu dhabi eu ali feliz da vida
bandeira do brasil aquela alegria total
aí começou a fazer essas transformações
nas cidades mas de dentro do governo a
gente é de fora eu sou sociedade civil
comum mas a gente entra no governo a
gente hackeia lhe o governo no negócio
louco e não é sozinho pegado aqui o
governo não se faz só a gente faz com
100 mil pessoas são 100 mil pessoas
nessa rede aqui em dois anos
e aí eu volto para aquela primeira
pergunta lá no começo você escola bola
para fazer uma cidade melhor todos os
dias antes de morrer
eu queria que a gente junto construir
cidades melhores para o cidadão com o
cidadão é isso